the second official trailer for venom
let there be carnage has finally landed
and we've been treated to a heaping
serving of new content
there are also a few hidden easter eggs
that are fun to dissect so let's take a
look at the small details you may have
missed in the second venom let there be
carnage trailer
during the trailer eddie brock sits down
at his desk and looks at a daily bugle
article on his computer where cletus
cassidy is making headlines for his
crimes
while he looks over the report some
drawings are scattered in front of him
on the desk
written inside the trunk of a large tree
are the words to thee the strife was
given
between the suffering poets and literary
enthusiasts will recognize this as a
part of a stanza and lord byron's
prometheus
prometheus is about the greek type of
the same name known as the god of fire
and a trickster he often helped humanity
by stealing fire and giving it to humans
a traitor to the gods and a friend of
humans prometheus was punished by zeus
for his crimes
the poem primarily focuses on what
happens when one resists tyranny and how
powerful that is it'll be quite
interesting to see how this quote
directly connects to cletus
as well as why it's something that eddie
appears to be analyzing the new trailer
also references the daily bugle marvel's
most famous in-universe newspaper since
peter parker and eddie brock both work
for the company in the comics it isn't
surprising that the sequel calls back to
the publication
detective mulligan is reading a copy of
the paper in the first trailer and the
new footage shows eddie working on his
exclusive interview with cletus cassidy
for the bugle
when i get out of here and i will
there's gonna be carnage the layout of
the paper's next edition is shown on
eddie's laptop using the same logo
design as the sam raimi spider-man
trilogy but the baber's masthead also
reads west coast edition
so clearly the new york-based outlet is
expanded across the u.s
this honors eddie's comics backstory
while also keeping him away from new
york so that sony doesn't have to
explain where spider-man
is yet aside from all the symbiote
shenanigans the trailer also gives fans
a better look at naomi harris's shriek
locked up in the ravencroft institute
for the criminally insane before woody
harrelson's carnage breaks her out
harris briefly appeared in the first
trailer for the sequel which showed
shriek's glowing eye as she's curled up
in a ravencroft cell but this new
footage gives us a better look at her
ear piercing powers
the villain unleashes a devastating
scream in a car smashing the windshield
this is probably after her escape from
the institute since she's still dressed
in the same white detention outfit
shriek is a mutant in the comics but
it's not clear if this version of the
character will have the mutant gene
x gene in the venom sequel because
marvel studios now holds the rights to
the mutants and the x-men
shriek's eye is also glowing bright blue
as she's screaming in the new trailer
which could actually be a nod to another
surprising ability she has
not only can she unleash a sonic scream
she can draw out someone's inner
darkness using her dark empathy which
causes her victims to commit unspeakable
acts
since she'll be partnering up with woody
harrelson's carnage it wouldn't be
surprising if she helps turn san
francisco upside down using her
manipulative skills
in several trailer scenes eddie brock is
seen wearing a t-shirt underneath his
jacket that reads mumford phys ed
department
fans of beverly hills cops should
recognize this shirt immediately as
eddie murphy wears a similar shirt in
the r-rated 80s film murphy's character
axel foley is an alumnus of the
real-life detroit high school and he
wears a white and gray version of the
shirt in the film
in fact beverly hills cop producer jerry
bruckheimer graduated from the school as
well
the directors of beverly hills cop 4
revealed in 2017 that they would love to
have either hardy or channing tatum as
the sequel's main antagonist
is this hardy's way of telling us he's
been cast or is interested in the film
probably not but here's hoping check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you